- Well, Tyler and I were
just talking about our kids
and you've got a daughter, right?
- I do, I have a--
- [Kelly Clarkson] How old is she? Three?
- A three and a half year old girl.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Three and a half.
- Yeah. Her name is Jackson.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh.
(audience swoons)
- [Kelly Clarkson] oh my
God, look at that picture.
- [Tyler Perry] Great age.
- [Parker Young] Yeah we're
we're big Kelly Clarkson fans
in our household.
- Great taste (laughs)
- I'm a little bit
embarrassed to say that uh,
that I have spent too
many mornings dancing
to your music with her.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God.
- This morning was, uh, Stronger.
We were dancing, jamming out. She uh--
- I love that you do
that with your daughter.
You're like, she's a daddy's girl.
- [Parker Young] Oh my goodness, yeah.
She uh, she's like, can I come with you?
I'm like, sorry, sweetheart.
Not on this one,
but
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh.
- I told her I would
ask a question for her.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- And her question is--
- Next time you should bring her.
- I would love to.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- I would love to. Yeah uh,
her question is what
is your favorite color?
- Oh, my favorite color is green.
- [Parker Young] Green? Okay.
Hers is gold sparkle.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Gold sparkle.
- Gold sparkle, yeah.
- Oh my God that's so cute.
There's a cute book she might like.
Channing Tatum actually wrote it.
It's called Sparkella.
My kids love it.
Anyway he was on here promoting it
and now I can't,
I read it every night, thanks Channing.
- He wrote it?
- Yeah, he wrote it.
He has a little girl.
but let's talk about your show.
So the show is powerful and timely.
So um if people haven't seen it um,
kind of explain a little about.
- Yeah, it's uh,
it's a show about a Marine um,
who's struggling to readjust
to civilian life in Ohio.
He's living with his Afghan uh,
and one of his best friends
is the Afghan interpreter
that served with his unit.
That guy comes to the
states to start a new life.
And the two of us are sort
of fumbling through this uh,
this next chapter in our lives.
- Yeah.
- I feel very grateful
that I have all these relationships with,
with um,
with a bunch of veterans and,
and active duty guys.
I feel like it wouldn't
be my story to tell if I,
if I didn't have a lot of this experience.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- [Tyler Perry] You know
what's amazing about it?
Chuck Lorre did this if I,
if I'm not, if I'm not mistaken
he did this before everything
happened in Afghanistan.
- [Parker Young] Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I know
that's what I was gonna ask you.
So what happened,
like when all that happened
I know a lot of people are
trying to get loved ones out.
- Yeah, it was,
it was um,
I mean first of all it was such an honor
to be in a position to try
and affect some semblance
of positive change
amidst that chaos and,
and, and destruction.
But it was a really sad time as,
as you can imagine we
have a lot of Afghans
and Afghan Americans on set
both in front of the camera
and behind the camera.
And they were devastated.
I mean everyone was in tears.
They're watching this
country that they love
disintegrate and be
taken over by the Taliban
and um.
- And fearful for like family members.
- So fearful.
Yeah, so even though we were
in the middle of production,
priority number one became
trying to help our coworkers
get their loved ones outta the country
before it was too late.
So, um, you know, me
and my coworker Adhir,
our military advisor,
and one of our Afghan writers flew to D.C.
to try to ask the president
to, to do everything
that he could to help these men and women
that have served our country
alongside our troops.
- Mhm.
- And um, our, our,
our military advisor,
guy named Chase Millsap,
he was on the phone day and night
with marines on the ground in Afghanistan
trying to get loved
ones out of the country.
It was, it was chaos.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's a truly heroic.
- [Parker Young] It was, it was heroic.
And, and we were ultimately successful
and got a handful of people out.
- That's great.
- It was really cool.
And then like uh.
- Like if you do nothing
else in your life,
that is,
what an amazing footprint.
- I felt so great.
And, and we ended up using
that experience to inspire our,
our season two premier episode,
which was about my character
and the interpreter getting,
fighting to get his sister out of country.
So talk about art imitating life.
I mean, the lines really
started to blur there.
- And I also love it's kind of similar,
like the Madea thing.
You take it's,
it's a humorous show, it's a comedy.
- [Parker Young] Yeah.
- But there are real messages happening.
- Congrats by the way, man.
That's, that's on,
Madea coming to Netflix.
- Oh. Thank you. Thank you.
- [Parker Young] Such a fan.
(audience claps)
Yeah. I, I think that--
- But hold on,
you can't compare Madea
and rescuing people from Afghanistan.
I mean, come on.
(audience laughs)
- No, no, no I was saying like the fact
that you have comedy though
and you actually have a
message like with it as well.
- You take real, heavy situations
and you try to find a
way to make it funny.
And I think there's nobody
that does it better than Tyler Perry.
(audience claps and cheers)
- [Kelly Clarkson] So funny.
Amen.